[Music]
here I know the last time I saw you
well you guys saw yeah we were we shot
that a couple of weeks ago and I was
stunned at how really nude we had to be
to shoot that this was your idea
I said yes I went over to set and you
were practically nude well I first of
all I have all fairness I would like to
say that people are now talking about
you as a sexy person right that wasn't
happening before no you put me on the
map see man it's right here in this
interview it says sexiest pecs in
Hollywood and he's right next to Liev
Schreiber and the guy from The Bachelor
oh yeah
[Applause]
here's the thing here's the thing I was
so Andy has that photo okay would you
mind taking your handout from Huertas
when I'll keep my hand really I asked I
had requested for Andy to be in the
shower scene with us but you were I
guess insecure about your body no no
someone was there just keeping us apart
darling right I'm very excited I was
very excited I mean my team my group of
writers said I don't you come I don't
know if Conan's gonna be into this idea
I don't know that he's gonna want to be
naked I said I've hugged him I felt his
body I felt like you were in really good
shape if anything you made me not look
great I thought you looked at first of
all fantastic I was offended because
people were so shocked that I was in any
kind of shape at all no I really was I
really was because the common reaction
was what a shocking surprise that Conan
O'Brien isn't hideous you know and so I
was just you know even my wife was like
oh I had no idea
seriously
it was it was I think it was a very
pleasant surprise for a lot of people
because people don't look at you and
think wow that guy's packing heat you
know and so I think it was
it was a great opportunity and it was
great because I'm sure your wife hasn't
seen you naked in a while either because
I'm telling you when we were in bed
together I wear this suit the covers are
up to my chin and I'm like touch me
single-tier you feel you feel more I
feel more in touch with my masculine
side thanks to you and you know I was
yeah we stood there it took hours to
shoot any other there's a part where you
slap me and you apparently don't know
how to stage slap where the hand goes
right across and so you got I think and
I'm not exaggerating about a hundred
takes of you hitting me as hard as you
could in the face and the director keeps
saying let's do it again let's do it
again and sometimes you were imprecise
and this part of your arm would hit me
so somewhere that was it it wasn't fair
because at first I didn't want to tell
him when the slap was coming because I
wanted it to be organic and then I saw
the tears welling up in your eyes
and it really hurt really I mean it was
it was very painful he's acting like a
real and I was and I felt terrible
but I had to keep hitting em to keep
doing it I mean I would do it now fit
and have rings on it because I would
just want to I want you to feel what
it's like to you should feel it it was a
graph it was okay then it was really
really painful and then I started to
become aroused it was just this it's
true it was sexy he had an erection for
about three-quarters of the day after
only after I started hitting him because
he was wearing board shorts for the
first half and then he actually had to
slap me with you know his little
boom-boom and he I mean why not a little
boom boom it was a I mean I don't know
how big it is but anyway I mean you're
you're Irish so I can only see I mean
I've been I'm rockin pretend
I'm not gonna pretend that I have not
been slapped in the face with a penis
before I have never been slapped in the
face with a white person's penis I don't
have to speak at all you just you just
clear it up that was the my next eight
questions says right here what kind of
penis have you been hit with